[Music
] cheers héctor mejía with the
headlines for today friday
december 18 a mother is accused of
killing her 3 year old son after an
accidental shooting on wednesday afternoon
according to detectives jasmine vargas
fired the gun while showing it to
friends
vargas  faces charges of
child abuse resulting in death
and a woman was struck and killed
Thursday night near warm
springs and spencer streets the incident began
as a minor accident between two cars
when the woman went out to investigate the
damage then was struck by  another
car and died investigators
suspect that the driver of the car
that hit her was driving
drunk
the state of nevada is registering the
highest number of
hospitalized patients for the coronavirus in the
entire country
state officials or suspect that
this wave of cases  comes from the
thanksgiving holiday weekend
nevada is seeing more than double the number of
cases of people infected
compared to the cases during the
summer doctors are concerned that
another wave of cases will be seen again after
the December holidays
and the public transport system is
using technology to contain and
control the spread of coronavirus they
announced that they are using a
portable device to  Taking
body temperatures in eight of its
establishments works in such a way that
the person stands in front of a
camera and the device takes their
temperature when a high
temperature is detected, a second
check is taken and now a look at
the weather forecast after breaking  months
of drought last night we had rain the valley
will be able to see temperatures in the high
50s yes even warmer for the
weekend with temperatures in the 60s
for Sunday for the start of the week and
to welcome winter no
temperatures are anticipated  cold until
Christmas Eve and Christmas
I am Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
informative  Kirchner in Spanish
[Music]